wait you've got to see this now we're  going to show Mom the magic trick of  where we can release the pressure  I know you want it  this right here is one of the biggest  calming buttons in the baby so if ever  she is struggling to latch if we just  put pressure here see how she  immediately like releases the tension  meet lactation consultant Danielle her  job is to support moms and babies in  their breastfeeding Journey Danielle  uses cranial sacral therapy to release  tension and then shows moms the  different pressure points they can use  to communicate with their babies anger  here  anchor here just gently pull her  shoulder down  she's loving this you guys how cool is  that follow her at Danielle Gauss i b c  l c for more  [Music]